[Music]
so
founded 1988
interesting opening what comes to mind
here
uh just pinning knight ninja absolutely
back
so more active depend the night of
course yup
thanks wasted way for the prime
okay so here already you need to put
your tactical detector whenever you have
a pin
that pawn's now hanging it bingo hard
exactly
very good
okay and his position spirals out of
control
what comes to mind here oh just
development castling
so that's one option but once you have a
knight on e5 and bishop on b5 what
other thing do you have to consider
anything catch your eye in terms of that
pin
um take a look at his knight on c6
how many attackers do you have on that
night i now have
two oh i see i can win a rook i take
with knight he does exactly
bishop yeah technically you win the
exchange uh because he takes back the
bishop
so like technically it's like only an
exchange but that's not a pretty bad
outcome
from the open yeah yeah we're we're up
on points here
yeah i mean it's not great to win the
exchange by move nine but you know it'll
do
all right now you want to get the hell
out of the center
or else he's going to give you a check
with his rook on e8
yeah so now i just want to develop yeah
exactly
perfect and now again the key is when
you win material
your first priority afterwards should be
as you're pointing out
development it's easy to sort of get
low whoa wait a minute your first
priority should be to take free [ __ ]
yeah you're getting that free night
absolutely with check
yeah founded 1988 oh my god oh
another one oh my goodness
jesus oh you're just you're just mopping
it up you know they don't have buffets
anymore but
this reminds me of the good old days and
i would go to like the local indian
restaurant for lunch
mop up all the curries all in a row yeah
so
i was going to ask what's do i take this
pawn with check he takes with queen well
if he took with queen i take with queen
is it better to take the pawn on d5 or
just take the hanging one on h7
so the d5 pawn is the juicier morsel but
there's a funny i would take the d5 pawn
with the queen
and the reason behind that is a very
funny one if you take with the knight he
goes king up to d6
and all of a sudden your queen is
hanging and your knight is actually
hanging
his queen on e8 is attacking it so i
would play it simple go for the queen
trade you actually force the queen trade
because his bishop is hanging
and uh remember that like i would draw
the informal threshold at
uh a rook if you're a rook upper or more
you should be very safe
going for an end game like you know
you're gonna win that
but we'll we'll take a quick look at
this after the game this knight takes d5
move
okay holy [ __ ]
this guy is is one of the most selfless
opponents i've ever seen
ooh um if i deliver check e1 with rook
is that better
perfect okay perfect move bringing the
pieces into the game
oh my goodness
that's mate now oh it actually is i
actually missed it i was so attracted by
the rook i didn't see that you could
made a money seven
oh no i immediately recognized that i
don't i don't know if you even need my
coaching anymore charlie i think
you've graduated to the upper ranks of
the russian school of chess you need
somebody
better qualified wow holy smokes what a
game
okay so just very very quickly um before
you jump actually why don't you jump
jump into the next one and then we'll
analyze both at once and zero on a roll
all right let's get another one going
yeah there's just one or two moments in
this game
oh you know i hate the one letter
followed by many numbers
it's never a good sign he's smurfing how
does this guy remember his
his login i wonder if like his computer
is wiped
okay
or night's defense
is it best to just castle now or push
the pawn dude
or d4 uh i would castle first
although both are fine but i would
castle first and i like that you're
thinking about going d4 and one fell so
p's screwing around on the sides of the
board
so opening up the center makes perfect
sense okay so now i can just play d4
perfect
yeah this a6 okay so d5 he's playing on
the flank
and now you have several interesting
possibilities
you can play it simple though
um so what i looked at was just pushing
the pawn
again and attacking the knight and just
doing a trade is that
so pushing it forward or taking his pawn
uh i was just gonna well either work i
looked at d5 first attacking that knight
there
so the idea is correct but while you're
at it you might as well open up the
center so
taking on e5 with the pawn same idea but
at least you're you're winning upon
you're opening up the center
um the move if you had gone def okay i
said whoa right you four
it doesn't take your bishop now think
about which
new squares have opened up for that
bishop yeah
right there at d5 beautiful
pinning his knight and now look at the
knight on g4
it's got only one okay so you can win
that night
yeah i just pushed this pawn upright
it's got nowhere to go exactly and if he
takes on e5 with his knight then what do
you do
he probably will do that
if he takes on e5 with his knight yeah
oh yeah i just take with my knight right
exactly undefended pieces and um
i'm gonna hammer that constantly
undefended pieces
uh all the time particularly the bishop
on d5 bishop on b7 that's a standoff
and you always want to kind of note that
down because that can really really help
you
yeah he's um okay
there we go so now just take this bad
boy back
and you absolutely do oh we got free
move holy smokes it's trying to
intimidate you
all right we're facing some
highly generous opponents today what
comes to mind
well i looked at just taking pawn on f7
with bishop
so you can take it in one of two ways uh
actually that's good you can take it
with the bishop but you can also take it
with the knight
and uh either move is fine why don't you
take with the bishop
because i want to see again speaking of
sabotage
i just like to watch you suffer and i
want you to try i want to see you find
the best move after he moves his king
thank you guys all for the subs ratings
are refunded guys that chess.com is
aware of this ratings are refunded
okay now it's important to deconstruct
what's going on here right
what what what is your instinct what
does your gut tell you
well the first thing i looked at was
getting my queen into the equation
bringing her
up to d5 protects that hanging knight
and it also gets her into the attack but
i don't know if that's the play
okay but are you sure it protects the
knight because he's got two attackers on
the night you've got only one defender
so you need to you need to untangle
yourself and you have just the way to do
that just trade
some pieces just
i'm just trading nights then trading
nights right because you have another
good square if you move your knight then
he takes your bishop
true so it's a good idea for you to
practice
just playing it very simple keep
simplifying can you force another trade
yeah i can just bring my bishop back to
d5 right exactly
you're up a piece and you're still
attacking it's not like you're
relinquishing the attack
now do i want to take with the pawn or
take with the knight or queen
thanks for the subs um all three moves
are fine
follow your instincts here okay i'm
going queen because it attacks
good that's a good that's a great move
okay now you want to think about what
are the weaknesses that have been
created as a result of this move like
what squares
does that c pawn no longer defend can
you get your queen to that square
move your ass yeah i don't see what that
relinquished
it's fine you can move the queen
anywhere these kinds of decisions the b6
square is what i was referring to
b6 yeah that square the pawn on c7 used
to control it now the pawn is on c6
it's no longer controlling it oh so just
dropping it back and moving it up yes
exactly and that's something we're going
to practice
okay the famous relinquished squares
exercise i'm surprised you haven't heard
of that one
just a little rusty it's been a minute
he will get you in killer form okay
keep developing yeah keep bringing
pieces into the game
bring the pieces in
uh so active square for the
well what about moving eight i'm just
gonna play this guy
yeah a4 is great opening up the a file i
was also thinking you could bring the
rook into the game rook 8 to d1 but this
is great if he allows okay now you can
take on b5 and it's just going to be
made down the a file
okay you have check made in two moves
yeah it starts with a queen at a7 right
nice a4 was a great move actually
okay now he's starting to think i think
it's just a tiny bit too late
yeah it's only he only has one spot
right now it's bb-8 for the mate b8 or
c7 or a8 or a6 you have four different
made to choose from
actually very nice i'll do this one
yeah very clinical okay so let me invite
you to an analysis board we'll just take
a very quick look at these
couple of moments in these two games
nice how do you feel in general do you
feel
confident do you feel like there's
anything you are particularly nervous
about or
like what's going on inside of your head
right now just so i kind of know
probably openings is my weakest part at
the moment would be my
thought would you be down to take a look
at a little bit of that today
oh you just you take me by the hand and
you lead me through whatever you want
you are a dream student i just have okay
wait a compliment to you again i've
started to do that a little bit more
recently and i hate that
i'm becoming soft okay let me invite you
my russian ancestors are not happy
there we go
uh oh wait hold on i think i need to
exit this
yeah let me know if you need me to
invite you again oh yeah
normally when a gm invites you you want
to rsvp but all right i'll make an
exception for you this time
there it is there we go all right i'm
ready all right so
this is we can start with the second
game um so yeah uh
the way that we'll revamp so f5 is oh
you know this is actually the first game
f5 is a very weird move um it's kind of
like a king's gambit except he's playing
with black it's no good
and this was great that should be five
putting pressure on the pawn
the way you played this was ideal so
knight takes c6 this makes sense right
bishop takes you win the exchange
castling is very important
okay he literally blunders everything
the one thing i wanted to point out here
okay yeah so here the move knight takes
d5 is super tempting but
whenever your queen is hanging that's
like
a particular type of category whenever
your queen is hanging
that is a very high pressure situation
that is a precursor to a lot of mistakes
you got to be very careful about how you
handle those situations because
here the king can go up to d6 and
the issue with the queen being hanging
in general is you almost always need to
do something about that so your your
hands are really really tight
queen has to move and then black takes
on d5 now it's not a big deal let's say
you had blunder that
where would you go with your queen
uh are we talking about after he takes
my knight with his queen
uh in this position so you kind of have
to prepare for him taking the knight
what would be the best
square for the queen in terms of making
the job easier assuming you
you've made this mistake oh you actually
have a really cool move that
doesn't lose any pieces but i'll show
you that afterwards
hmm you have a very pretty move
it took me a while to see that one
actually
so remember the rook is the threshold so
you do want to trade queens here
can you guarantee that you will trade
queens after he takes on d5
the only place i see is just moving it
down to like d3 and just
preparing for it exactly d3 or h5 that's
all all that i had in mind just tying
the queen to the knight
trading and what would be the next move
here
um get the bishop out charlie
i i was thinking a pawn move
but i don't know where you'd move except
delivering a check on c4
well then the king takes yeah but
remember that beeper that's all i would
you would but you don't have
a queen if you had a queen that would be
great the problem is this is an end game
so
remember that in the end game the rules
don't really change you still need to do
the same stuff
that you would want to do in the middle
game i.e develop your pieces you're not
going to win this game
with these pieces of crap just lounging
around on a1 and c1 so get them out
just like you would in a middle game
you just develop you just push that pawn
up d3 absolutely d3 then bishop b3 and
rookie one
so i'm going to put the emphasis in
general having as many of your pieces
doing something as possible
if you just follow that simple rule uh
things are not going to be that bad
like that's going to eliminate getting
crushed basically
uh and in the end game you do exactly
the same thing it's
even more important to have all of your
pieces playing because you don't have a
lot of them left
so does that sort of make sense yeah
that makes sense perfect
and the now the second game so let me
see
how do i paste this one okay i'm gonna
have to reinvite you to another
motherboard oh good i mean you're
getting two invitations now
this is your lucky day all right
invited
all right oh yeah okay they want to see
that okay i'll show the cool move later
um the cool moves knight takes c7 it was
not like nothing to write home about
okay
so here um h3 h6 a6 and you open up the
center right your opponent
is screwing around you open up the
center uh and now d takes e5 so you want
it initially to play d5 the problem with
this move
is that it closes up the center and
black does not have to take your bishop
let's say black just drops the knight
back to b8
okay you have to move the bishop right
and black ghost d6
when you have a lead in development as
you already know you want to open up the
center
and when you've got this structure the
center is very closed which means that
even though you have more pieces
developed that loses its
effectiveness if that makes sense okay
so that's why the move d5 it also closes
down your bishop so d takes e5 does the
same thing
but had he taken your bishop the center
is a lot more open and you have a very
very nice move here very natural move
accumulating the pressure in the center
yeah he's pushing the pawn upright
you can do that that's one one way can
you play a piece move
attacking the queen
oh yeah just developing to the d5
exactly he's got to go back now where do
you put the bishop
now the bishop just goes through a
foreign bingo he's got to go you're
attacking the spawn now tear this [ __ ]
apart the move you wanted to play
earlier
who wanted to play earlier yeah
oh that's pretty big what move did i
want to play earlier yeah there were
several
that's an extremely helpful him what are
you talking about earlier in this game
oh i'm just pushing the pawn absolutely
e5 and you open up the file and he's
absolutely busted here so very simple
following the principles and
black's just going to get demolished
here so that was um
a possible continuation sorry he went um
d5
he went knight g4 bishop d5 bishop b7 h3
and there's only one other thing that i
wanted to
show you after he took then everything
was very simple
he has a interesting move h5
this is called a i think a fishing pole
trap
this isn't actually a trap in this
position but that's the basic idea so
what what is the meaning of the move h5
well basically the idea
is if you take do you see what kind of
could happen here
let's say you you dropped your knight to
h2 nonchalantly black is already
not winning but it's unpleasant yeah so
he's just gonna bring his queen over to
the h file right exactly
now it's very hard to defend against
checkmate white has only one defense
here
luckily can you find it it's trading
queens
right no no that wouldn't do it yeah
because queen takes h2 isn't going to be
made
yeah um is it just bringing the bishop
up to
f4 bingo only move without this move it
would have been checkmate but the way to
just avoid all of this is to play knight
g5
stopping the queen from coming to h4
so just wanted to raise your awareness
that when there is a piece on g4
and you are attacking it with h3 uh your
opponent may play this move and there
you have to evaluate whether or not you
can take the knight or the bishop
whatever is on g4
and make sure that the pathway to h4 is
covered up okay
makes sense so that's basically it
everything else was extremely smooth
okay perfect so um i think we can
divide this next segment into two
sections we can talk a little bit about
openings
and i want to sort of start talking
about building up positional
understanding
and do a little bit of a drill uh that
involves that involves that
looking at the position perhaps in ways
that you're not quite used to
does that sound good and then after that
we can jump back in for a couple games
good to me man perfect let me just pull
up my notes
and just got a couple couple of
positions that i
have here one moment
so let's begin with some review we had
looked at this position
many many moons ago uh and this is
this position is what i would call a
gateway into positional understanding
so i'm going to paste this position in a
moment and let me know if you can see it
because
always glitches this is of course a game
between two russians because what other
game would i ever show you
that's the only games that matter and
part of what i brought with me home
to charlotte is a book called the it's
simply called the path to mastery not
even the path to chess mastery the path
to mastery
um i'm translating this is written in
1970 in the soviet union
this is like the ultimate russian school
of chess so some of the positions i show
you are going to be from this book it's
one of my chairs
cherished possessions yeah that sounds
like a crazy book
well the funny thing is it's written by
a military sergeant who was also a chess
master and he talks about basically
every facet of chess improvement
and he would only find this in like a
soviet book some of the chapter names i
[ __ ] you not
by the way the table of contents in
russian books is always at the end of
the book
um okay get this blah blah blah the
hygiene of a chess player
my my stream knows this because i read
from it the hygiene of a chess player
the um athletic regime of a chess player
increases the chances of success that's
the name of the challenger
various roads to the heights of chess
olympus
uh on the path to mastery of an army
chess player
so literally he talks about absolutely
everything and he talks about
actual chess facets so anyway sorry to
ran about it but it's an interesting
little relic
have you been hitting the gym in
response to this are you getting kind of
[ __ ] jacked right now
i don't even leave the gym in my
apartment building
i mean the tread between the treadmill
and the weights i'm
basically playing chess on the treadmill
beautiful
but that's what this guy would have
recommended so okay
this position is going to help us review
some of the very basic positional
content what is positional chess in
general
what do i want you to master positional
chess can be summarized
in very very simple terms positional
chess just means
improving peace placement the art of
finding the best
spots for your pieces and there's a lot
of sub
sub concepts right that's not literally
all there is to it but that's what
everything is essentially
uh boils down to okay and that's what i
want
want to make you a an absolute wizard at
so let's take a look at this position
you
do you see it uh on yours yes okay let
me see yeah you do perfect
it is white to play this game is from
1945.
uh first i'm not going to tell you
anything i want you to try to understand
what's going on here
why to move all right well the first
thing i looked at
was just getting queen up going to g3
seems like an active square it threatens
a checkmate
potential on g7 by getting the bishop
over to h6
it also protects the bishop still in
case there is an attack on it
okay pretty good thinking
the e4 pawn is defended only by the
knight
the knight can't be taken because it's
still got the b2 pawn protecting so that
all looks pretty good
okay interesting so we'll talk about
what black should do in a second
let's also practice a little bit of
visualization calculating in your head
if in this position and i'm not going to
make this move black takes on e4 with
his knight
yeah i just saw that yeah white actually
wins the white wins there
calculate further you take blacks knight
and black takes
your night with this queen and that
position in your head i want you to find
the move
so queen take took back knight on e4 yes
right to play right to play and win a
piece
not the easiest move to see but you got
to think about how the position has
changed
what what is now possible which used to
be impossible
and you know which square you have to
target
the move is f6 i don't expect i'm muted
i don't expect charlie to see it but
we're gonna make him better at
visualization that's gonna be super
important i want him to be able to
calculate
two three move lines in his head this is
gonna be torturous at first
but trust me this will pay off
anything coming to that genius mind
uh there's a couple cobwebs on here i
gotta dust off it seems yeah i'm not
seeing oh and
look i'm completely understand this is
gonna be challenging at first so what
you need to target here is that g7 pawn
yeah yeah yeah i see but instead of
targeting with the bishop you target
with the pawn
bingo f6 and if bishop takes f6
uh then i'm uh some bishop f6
um
don't i just then slide over to h6 well
then but then you're not threatening
uh anything on g7 you can actually just
take that bishop
because why can't pawn take the rook
because it's pinned right now because
it's pinned right so as soon as you put
the queen on g3 you're like aha this
pawn is spin so knight takes e494 queen
e4 f6
double attack bishop f6 rook f6 and
white is up with these
yeah okay very good and i'm sorry to
torture you with these lines i'm gonna
do a lot of that because i want you to
start
reliably visualizing three three four
move lines by
sort of the start of of pogchamps but
here's the thing that black can do
black can just slide his king over to aj
and uh this takes the sting completely
out of the move queen g3 because now
there's no longer a pin
yeah and would it make sense if i said
that white isn't really attacking
there's no way to lift the rook
everything is awkward the e4 pawn is now
actually hanging
white starts to crumble a little bit
does that part make sense yeah so this
is
a great example of a position in which
attacking your opponent's king just
isn't going to do the trick you need to
find an alternate approach to the
position
in order to do that the concept of weak
squares
comes into play can you spot a very weak
square
in position and i remind you by
definition a weak square is a square
that cannot be defended by a pawn
there's
one juicy central square if only you
could get a piece there
yeah isn't it d5 it is what would you
like to get to d5
would putting the knight on that outpost
be the player abso [ __ ] lutely and i
like that you referenced uh the outpost
unfortunately you can't do that
immediately though because black
black snide is gonna have something to
say about that
but here comes the key idea
am i finding the key idea you are
absolutely finding the idea
you are going to find it i have no doubt
at all
or we're never going to have a lesson
again i'm just kidding okay
so we need to get the knight off of that
d5 square
to so get the hell out of there are we
just chasing it down with the bishop
going to g
five exactly bishop g5 is the brilliant
mode
because the knight is pinned he cannot
move right and whatever black does in
the game
uh rutakovsky black played rook aca
smith love
i think no he played i think h6
smithslav takes on f6
and he slams the knight into the outpost
on d5 amazing square
and uh now white has complete dominance
over the bishop
how do you capitalize from this position
though like where's the line go from
here
so basically uh and actually let me let
me look up exactly what black did play
now black played rook f to e8 sorry
rook ft e8 that's a great question um
well we're first going to take a look at
how the game ended because the game ends
very very quickly
essentially the idea is only now to
attack black's king
because you have this amazing knight
you've eliminated counter play the e4
pawn is safe
now our hands are untied for a king side
attack but
first of all queen takes c2 seems to be
a free pawn for black but it's actually
not
can you figure out why not
and the concept of tactical awareness
comes into play here
this knight on d5 is wearing a lot of
hats and there's a particular square
that it now wants to get to
uh so i see two options there's
just taking the bishop on f6 delivers
the check
and he has to take with the pawn that
opens up the g file i don't know like
where to capitalize there but right
sorry guys and then i also notice
there's a fork potential at c7 without
very good that is actually the correct
observation remember that the queen is
the worst defender of a square because
queens can be very
easily chased away get rid of this damn
queen
just going to see one with the rook
bingo queen has to move
four kvitch and you win the exchange
white is better white is
basically winning so pretty simple
knight d5 now how
does the actual game end black plays the
move bishop to d8 he moves his bishop
away smithslav decides now to defend the
pawn with c3
b5 black tries to make something happen
b3 very patient typical russian move
first get the queen out of c4 get
freaking queen also there so i cannot
pack
uh like i am supposed to yeah b3 queen
c5 king h1
black goes rook c8 now is black actually
threatening anything with this move
no it's still defended by the knight
it's defended by do you see how
freaking amazing this it is both
defending and attacking
um now smithslav wins the game with a
very typical attacking technique you
like this particular plan
and it's a perfect time to do it
say that again is it the initial one by
sliding up to g3
uh you're close but not with the queen
with
what this is a plan that allows you to
bring a piece into the attack
oh are we doing a rook lift we are
absolutely doing with rock f3
oh okay and black tries to hide on h8
with his king
but that's just about as effective as me
i don't know
hiding under a desk when you're about to
get blasted by
a huge bomb and smithslav now plays
another really nice move he plays f6
and the point of this move is that you
intercept the bishop where do you want
this queen to go
h4 exactly so we intercept the bishop
and um black plays g takes f6
smith's love goes queen h4 look how
methodically he brings pieces into the
attack rook g8
and very symbolically the knight is the
piece that basically wins the game
knight takes f6
threatening checkmate rook g7
now another very nice move rook g3
distracting the rook from g7 if
backwards to take
then what happens no no it's just
checkmate
checkmate on it yeah so bishop takes f6
was played there's only two more moves
in the game
now whoops sorry now black has to defend
the rook with rook c
to g8 is this sort of making sense so
far yeah and now smizlov plays
the second move that i want you
basically to find what often happens
when you are attacking is as we
discussed many times you develop
a kind of tunnel vision because what do
you see here
what is the what seems to be the square
that you're going to win the game
on what are you attacking with all your
might
uh it looks like we'll win at g7 exactly
but that's an illusion and one of the
things that you have to start doing when
you are attacking
is continually look at the whole board
because sometimes your opponent is so
invested in defending a particular
square
that there is another pawn or another
square that just becomes really weak and
you can deploy the remaining pieces
and and infiltrate through that
particular square
and that's exactly what he does yeah so
right i mean he can't take with the rook
right now because it's pinned to the
game so
you just get the next rook into the
attack right by going to like
f1 and bringing it up so you're very
close think about where
how can this rook uh infiltrate as
quickly as possible there is a pawn that
is basically indefensible rook f1 is
almost correct
there's just a faster way of doing this
is it d1
bingo sorry that was a mouse slip rook
e1 would be
dumb rook d1 is the move because you're
just going to take the pawn on d6
and let's make a random move for black
what is the actual now checkmating
sequence
uh i believe it's rook
d8 take on d8 with lens
yeah okay and now just this is made you
can also by the way you can sack the
queen on g7
and now go rook d8 this is also this is
kind of a cool name
so yeah i definitely didn't see that one
yeah but i mean
no need to play with fire if you see a
simple mate you want to go for a simple
mate
so that basically is key positional
concept number one
you want to get a piece to a square and
you want to continually start okay where
does this piece belong
where does this piece belong how can i
reposition this piece to that square
and often times there will be an
opponent's piece that is in the way
and you want to try to get that
opponent's piece out of the way okay
that's sort of
key gateway concept number one now
concept number two we're going to take a
look at a segment from one of my games
uh this won't be long it'll just be sort
of one position the concept of traits
right and if you remember when we first
started training
it was a very dark period of my life i
was having a great time and then of
course
they assigned you to me and everything
kind of went downhill from there
but one of the few fun moments was uh
to watch your aversion to trades right
you've gotten
so much better at that but do you
remember when you like just didn't want
to [ __ ]
trade anything i remember those
beautiful days those days the dark ages
of uh it was back in the days of the
bubonic plague and
bought it yeah i mean it was just a
horrible time a young nubile boy back
then
uh it was oh those times
okay so of course you can use trades to
your
uh advantage and oftentimes what you
have to do in a position is identify
your opponent's
strongest piece this is sometimes a hard
process sometimes an easy process we'll
look at an introductory position where
this is easy
and then you need to devise a way to
trade that piece
sometimes and this is the important part
you need to use tactics
to achieve a positional goal you need to
use tactics to trade
a particular piece um if that makes
sense
so a good illustration is one of my old
games
you are going to be playing black here
so flip the board
i want you to go through this process i
want you to a identify
white's strongest piece and b find the
quickest way to trade it using tactics
not an easy position but i think you can
do it wait did i just encourage them
this is child's play daniel oh this is
you were doing this when you're in your
mom's room basically oh yeah
oh yeah this is this is too weird this
is freaking
this is an insult actually i'm sorry i'm
giving you this position relates
so what is the strongest piece what is
white's most annoying and you can
use your eyes here just visually his
strongest piece is the knight on d5
right now
his strongest piece is the knight on d5
so you would love to get rid of the
knight that night constitutes white's
entire advantage
this is the hard part so take your time
oh wait i see it is it a i'm dropping
knight to e7
yeah there we go freaking got it 97
temporary sacrifice queen c5 check and
then you win back the knight
and the position is equal it's a queen
end game um and the knight has been
gotten rid of nice now let's imagine
that black
had uh instead tried to prepare this
move by playing queen to e6
now flip the board and face white
another positional task
identify black's biggest weakness and
pile up on it
and this shows why queen e6 is a very
key mistake
so scour the board when i say weakness
it can be a pawn
it can be a piece it can be anything
evaluate
each particular region of the board see
if there's anything that seems to be
very flimsy
i mean i could slide my queen all the
way to h5
attacking his knight you're close that's
actually not a bad move the knight
has a hard time moving because if 97 and
white to play and win
yeah don't i just uh i'm just going like
straight down to
e8 right bingo winning the night because
of the pin but
that's possible but another possibility
is to attack this pawn on f6 why do i
see the spawn because this pawn is
cannot be defended by either of its
neighbors so by definition it's a weak
pawn
how can you attack it i
attack it by moving queen to f3 bingo
and you see that the pawn cannot be
defended notice also the pawn on g3
uh something i want you to file away in
that mental rolodex of yours
um which of course is you know it's it's
almost full
with chest knowledge but just one little
factoid
when the knight is on the same file as a
pawn and there are two squares between a
knight and a pawn
both of which are on the same file that
is a very bad situation for the knight
so here we have that situation there are
two squares i'm highlighting in blue
between the jeep on and the knight
right and do you see why this is a
horrible situation for the night
i mean pardon my french yeah go ahead
yeah
because it can't move forward the pawn
defends both of its squares
yeah as they say in french in the night
is [ __ ] blocked it's a it wants to go to
f1 no
not okay that was just horrible i just
said the night
caught blocked if i may use that
expression
i get you um ever since i learned that
in
in fourth grade i had last year i cannot
stop using it
so the knight cannot go to network and i
got h4 just file that situation
away make a metal enough okay so does
this make perfect sense
okay so we're going to do a freaking ton
of various positional exercises let's
just do one
last one that kind of bridges the gap
between positional chests and tactics
then we'll talk a little openings
and then maybe a couple more games
so and thank you alexander merkel for
the prime
okay one of my blitz games
it is white to move in this position
and um part of
what we're going to build up is not only
the ability to evaluate trades and prove
pieces
but also the ability to sense when you
can basically launch a very quick attack
like noticing okay a position that looks
very peaceful
right this doesn't look like anything is
going on but in reality white is only a
couple of moves from winning the game
i want you to try to figure out why that
is and what move white can make here
this is going to be tricky but try to
make as many observations as you can
well i can't trade knights here because
i take night with knight he takes with
pawn and now my queen's being attacked
so that's definitely not the play
yeah yeah right that opens up the file
it's equal by the way this is not bad
for white but
it's clearly not uh you know the alpha
move
uh i was looking at getting queen on
king side for an attack by going to
g5 but i don't see where i'd continue
that attack
right and i remind you of one key thing
uh in terms of the queen's involvement
in the attack usually
when the queen is all alone in an attack
it's not always that effective that's
like
you know napoleon bonaparte uh freaking
you know going himself uh to the front
lines
the queen is like the general and and
she needs to be used in very specific
ways oftentimes
as the sort of uh support as the the
leader of the attack the queen can be
way behind in your territory like on g2
and doing just the same thing as it can
be on g5 but we'll talk about that
uh later okay good call on that one
i don't know what's gotten into me very
french
so what seems to be annoying you about
this position which one of black's
pieces
is it's the e5 right but you don't want
to take it so you want to find
an alternative way to chase that knight
away what comes to mind
uh well i'd have to move the pawn on f2
so i'd have to evacuate the knight first
and go i guess putting the knights on
i mean d4 doesn't seem terrible exactly
centralizing the night while you're at
it that is the move that i played very
nice knight d4
so i call this the wish list method some
positions
you want to just ask yourself well what
the hell do i want to do if i could have
anything i wanted whatever for christmas
and that could be anything i piece on a
particular square what is it because
sometimes that's closer to reality than
you might think
so black is a gm by the way this is uh i
was white and i was playing a gm knight
e to d7 was his move
continue he's trying to preempt me but
that doesn't mean i
i don't want to do what i wanted to do
earlier
by playing the pawn up absolutely f4
he goes knight to c5
keep it going
this king is very weak right there's no
fiance bishop you must open files
yeah i'm pushing this f pawn again to f5
right exactly
uh if he plays g takes f5 find the
winning move for white
don't rush again how as soon as a move
like this is made how is the position
changed when new avenues are available
to your pieces
yeah now i have the entire g file yup
queen g5 yeah wins the night exactly
good so bishop c8 f takes g6
h takes g6 and now basically the
critical moment or sorry he plays f
takes g6
he take he took with the other pawn now
i'll give you a hand there is a
sacrifice
that leads to a devastating attack
sacking the knight d4 to f5
very interesting move um and actually
that's probably
not bad at all but after g takes f5 you
will find that it's actually not that
easy to continue because if you give a
check here right that's what a way i
assume you wanted
that's what i was looking at then the
king can slide over to f7
it protects the knight it protects the
knight and here's the problem if you
play e takes f5
why is this bad conceptually
like this pawn right what's bad about it
i can't be defended by other well it can
be defended by the g pawn right that's
it's not about the pawn b you actually
want this knight this pawn to be gone
from the board right because that would
open the f5
so be very careful about that right it's
called i would call it the umbrella
method it's like your opponent is using
the pawn as an umbrella
sheltering his king okay so your right
area of the board of course
think of another sacrifice
the only other stack i see is the rook
taking absolutely you draw the king in
but now the key move and black resigned
after this move
the king wants to evacuate back to g7
you allow this i chopped her nuts off
yeah so you just want to slide the queen
all the way to h6 right bingo
and he resigned because look at the king
i mean the king is caught in the
crossfire rook f1
queen g7 this is all checkmate and this
is the kind of position i want you to
look at and you don't even have to
calculate anything it should be clear to
you
that white has overwhelming threat
threats against black skin does that
make sense
so very quickly let's say rook fake
continue
um
[Music]
and a painful little exercise finding
checkmate yeah
you know i know you love i'm still
sliding the rook over to f1 right
you are okay king if king e7
that's bringing the queen down to g7
nice made in two and if king e5 that is
the only move
there's many ways to finish the king off
i want you to find
one of them
thank you guys all for the subs i'll
thank you guys later i'm trying to keep
the flow of the lesson going thank you
ex xpowerslave and everybody for the
support
i hope you guys are having a good time
i'm certainly having a great time
watching charlie suffer
and in such positions it's important to
apply basic logic checks captures
threats you want to keep drawing the
king deeper and deeper into your
territory
do i just deliver a check at f3 with
that knight
very oops i don't know what that was
very solid move that basically forces
black to give up the rock
but you can actually sacrifice tonight
you can use it as
kind of a mousetrap because if the king
appears on d4 then there's going to be a
checkmate
what you need to do is compel the king
to go to d4
give a check for us there remember to
look at retreating moves
no so am i just bringing the queen back
to the fifth record exactly
king takes d4 and now the mate is
elementary
my dear watson
is the one you're talking about just
bringing the queen all the way to d2
whoa but now the king evacuates that
queen is fulfilling a crucial role
so you have to do it with another piece
you have oh my god
you have a very pretty checkmating
pattern
it's just the rook then huh it's the
rook yeah knight has the cover and then
it says
the move that i saw you could also give
this check
four king knight and the queen c takes
b5
check king has to take and now
rookie won and this sets up this is not
a check but look at how safe white's
king is this sets up a discovered mate
which is completely inevitable this is
actually just checkmate
anyways that's just me being stupid that
you absolutely don't have to do that
rook d1 is the simplest
okay so uh so does that make sense
yeah and so the key right what we're
going to work on is while we're working
on positional chess
uh it's i'm also going to try to help
you develop a sense for when
you can transition from quiet play to to
an attack
here you notice that ah the 95 is
annoying wait a second i can push this
pawn all the way to f5 by force because
black's got pieces kind of like bowling
pins
that you can just bowl over with your
pawn
and then that basically transforms to a
sacrifice
great so we'll do freaking [ __ ] tons of
these exercises they're gonna be in your
nightmares
uh but let's switch to openings
i'm gonna give you the choice between we
we have to look at white and black
openings
[Music]
you